all we're doing is basically onboarding
the 750 mobile operators on a platform
where any developer in the world through
any cloud provider can go ahead and
access these capabilities and not only
that you're able to use this private key
to do so there's so many data points
that your mobile operator has on you on
your locations which sells you are
connected what is the data imagine what
you can do if you can somehow create a
signature or multiple signature to
create more multiactor authentications
to do
[Music]
thatan welcome to 20 minute leaders in
the Maus experiment thank you for being
a part of my experiment how are you
thank you I so great to be here I'm
great exciting times really excited from
uh from our conversation wow all right
Aon um first of all you're you're a ser
and parallel entrepreneur I've gotten to
know you over over the the past few
years and it's very rare to have to meet
somebody who's both a a a a Serial
entrepreneur that and that you do many
Endeavors but then also you you
parallelize a lot of the things that you
do and uh and it feels that every every
conversation we have I I get introduced
to the to the to the reality as you see
it and and you're not confined to the
constraints of the reality that that we
objectively see in front of us which is
which is which is incredible So today
we're going to dive into to eran's work
in the context of Glide and and digital
identities and Next Generation identity
security a world which I'm I obviously
very curious about um having being
acting and playing in the world of deep
fakes myself but Iran thank you again
for being here tell me a little bit
about yourself how do you perceive
yourself in your own entrepreneurial
Journey
so first of all I'm I'm very curious so
I like to learn uh different fields and
I like to dive in into um different
areas I've been doing things um you know
from Enterprise software to algorithmic
trading to adtech to blockchain um stuff
and um um every time when I find
something that I feel that I can bring
real value in and I get curious about I
find myself into a new Journey so um
it's uh my life is not boring that's for
sure all right and so what brought you
to to digital identities where and and
where are we at today in the because I'm
sure that the evolution of what's
happened over the last couple of years
has led also to part of your um diving
into digital identities yeah so I would
say that my um my main interest in the
main uh in the the last several years um
is around positive alignment so actually
how to take a lot of different uh big
companies and forces in the world and
find a way a new model that they can all
align positively and uh create greater
value together and greater value to
humanity um the uh by set of coincidence
I got into the Telecom industry and um I
uh worked a long time of trying and and
still succeeding to align many big telas
like DOA Telecom vone like the big
giants um to work together in different
use cases and a successful uh Journey
we've done around with clex uh is around
blockchain based reconciliation and
settlement or basically trading
automation how to have this giant
multinational companies to have
frictionless trading and how they can
govern this uh in a in a joint way and
how to avoid a centralized party
basically controlling this so this is
one of the most successful experiments
in uh uh using blockchain in a
Enterprise environment and actually
succeeding to do something um together
working with this Telos is extremely
extremely
slow and while doing this um uh journey
and getting this into production doing
security privacy it procurement all that
stuff with this long sell cycle I came
across this amazing opportunity um to do
uh alignment in a even greater scale and
uh benefit not just the Telos but
humanity and that that uh that
opportunity is around exposing the
capabilities of um mobile networks and
Telos in general as apis to Developers
and this is uh relevant for multiple use
cases which I find identity um to be the
the most interesting one so by uh kind
of being in this field for almost seven
years now and knowing uh all these
telecom companies and understanding uh
we came across this opportunity of
aggregating um these API and this is all
done under a new initiative called open
Gateway uh which is kind of open banking
for Telecom
and um we became a very um uh like a
involved party uh in this and that gave
birth to Glide out of the clearex um uh
structure that is our new Endeavor to to
handle open Gateway and the identity for
the AI era wow okay so so a lot to
unpack there let's start with this with
where this is all the foundation of this
which is all about the alignment um and
and how do we we create a better value
for better society and better Humanity
those those are big words I I know you
mean them and I know you're very
intentional about them but um for for
clarity what do you what does that mean
what what does it mean to have for you
better alignment in in today's world so
a nice thought experiment is um to think
about um if all Telos were one company
okay or they were in some structure that
was the company if with the biggest
customer base in the world 5.6 billion
uh customers right the telephone number
is the biggest um used widely used
identity uh in the world that can
identify you anywhere and this comp this
um like a theoretical uh worldwide telom
has also commercial relationship with
almost any company in the world
providing um uh connectivity so so that
could be um ideally what gives us not
only our connectivity but also our
identity and our means of
payment um and you ask yourself why
still in
2024 the most um commonly used way of
authenticating our identity is an SMS
that we get that we all get these SMS
onetime passwords um uh throughout the
week which is more than 30 30y old
technology that is
unencrypted uh very weird user
experience sometimes you don't get it
sometimes you need to copy it you got a
huge wholesale Market with many
aggregators and gray routes and
politices and all kind of things where
we have you know um such an amazing
technology connecting all of us uh
allowing us to make this um uh video
recording today right and this is
because of lack of alignment this is
because uh all of these companies didn't
find a way to actually work together to
provide these new types of solutions and
there are many other example of this in
other Industries but with Telecom this
is so strong because if you think of it
I don't know any other service that
Humanity had that with this uh mobile
device you can get into any country in
the world and instantly get service even
if you go want to charge your uh phone
you have different kind of sockets and
different kind of Standards around
electricity if you drive a car sometimes
it's in the right side and the left side
whatever and this is like the the most
uh successful Universal solution so you
can see what happens when you have
alignment and what kind of value you can
bring to humanity and when you don't
have and this is of course not just in
Telecom that can happen around countries
around banking around energy many of the
utilities of the world if we would
consider them from a Global Perspective
we can create much more value with much
less uh effort absolutely okay so
transitioning from alignment to to Glide
and and I I want to unpack a little bit
I think it's it's important to note um
identity security is um one of the most
um interesting I think fields in today's
world um this the increase in fraud due
to account takeovers identity breaches
is um in the hundreds of percent um with
a you know there we have the it's
repeatedly in in all the reports from
crowd strike to Verizon to deoe and and
the the stories are just adding up
there's new modalities to attack whether
it's injection attacks presentation
attacks deep fake attacks um and so um
there's there's a lot of different ways
to now circumvent existing existing
identity security
mechanisms and and it's also important
to say that there's a large number of
identity security vendors there's about
95 last time I spoke with Gartner
identity security vendors and I haven't
heard yet of the of of of the concept
that you're looking at which is looking
at at it from a telecom perspective and
I wantan to so I want to make sure that
I really understand that properly so you
know I understand the things that people
are doing today with identity security
obviously multiactor authentication with
SMS biometric authentication liveness
detection deep fake detection can you
can you explain again and and maybe a
little bit more more intuitively what
what it how are you leveraging telecoms
and and where this positions Glide
because then you have a really
interesting model to the developer
Community exactly so I mean I think you
touched but we you mentioned few um few
types of identity protection or identity
authentication one of them is around
multiactor authentication right yeah and
you also mentioned SMS as one of them
the SMS is the current uh Telecom way of
doing authentication right so all we're
doing is we're saying hey there's so
many new technologies that we can
Implement today that can create a far
better multia multiactor authentication
solution using um uh Telecom providers
the basic thing to understand is that we
all walk around with a device that is a
kind of a a hardware wallet if you look
at it from a uh from a crypto
perspective right we have a private key
in our SIM card here with very good
encryption and we still use an a clear
text SMS so all we're doing is basically
on boarding the 750 mobile operators on
a platform where any developer in the
world through any cloud provider can go
ahead and access these
capabilities and not only that you're
able to use this um uh private key to do
so there's so many uh data points that
your mobile operator has on you right on
your locations which cells you are
connected what is the data imagine what
you can do if you can somehow create a
signature or multiple signature to
create more multiactor authentications
to do that so we provide a platform to
do that with confidential Computing with
different elements of privacy and
security to make it happen so basically
we are just Reinventing or helping Telus
to um provide what they've invested you
know the investment around 5G was so far
more than1 trillion dollar including
frequencies and uh and equipment1
trillion dollar you can imagine and this
is not being leveraged at all today in
the identity field so we are helping
exposing this by providing developers
all over the world through the cloud
provider to access these type of
identity Solutions so to make sure
understand you're basically saying there
is this entire industry that we've been
building which is called the
Telecommunications industry we've
invested enormous amounts of money in
anything from the 2G to 3G to 4G to 5G
um and that it's just increasing we're
you know it's a mature industry we use
it all the time this is what drives our
our our real-time communication channels
at the same time we have this Emer ing
problem that emerges called identity
security we're digitized we want to open
bank accounts through our through
digital identities we want to log in h
using H you know without constantly
having to to convince who we are and
we've developed mechanisms right we've
developed a multiactor authentication
through smss 30 years ago we've
developed more recent face recognition
biometric recognition which have their
own issues yet these two worlds have
never been connected in a meaningful way
way because you're effectively saying
there is potential in the in the data
that the telecommunication industry has
that if you just platform create a
platform around this data and you make
it accessible via apis and sdks to the
developer Community you can and you can
effectively create a Next Generation
multiactor
authentication which has better user
experience than the sms's and it also is
less prone to the breaches that smss
have is that right all right I want to
invest I got
it exactly and and because of all the
things that you you mentioned because of
deep fakes uh Biometrics are going to
become uh harder because like and this
is this is what you're exper how do I
know that you are you now right iol soon
it's going to be very hard but maybe I
can trigger now something that will pop
up in your phone and you can now
authenticate that this is actually you
right because you have already the same
SIM card for I don't know the 15 20
years that you have so the the the depth
of your the identity knowledge that the
Telco has is unprecedent the amount of
events that he has about you it's such a
strong uh way to to authenticate and to
verify you and and it goes even beyond
that because then it becomes uh then it
becomes uh not only to authenticate you
in the digital world but also in the
physical world when you go ahead to buy
um uh to to go to a hotel why do you
need to give your passport and and put
all the fields and wait seven minutes
until you want to do we call that
product that's me you want to tap it
into your payment your identity is just
there fully authenticated and that's it
you want to go ahead and rent a car why
do you need to put all these forms and
everything that's me and you got it so
there's so many areas where these apis
can create um a verification ease of use
and much better secure
absolutely aan this is such a such a
cool field that you're in and I think
that what what excites me most is it's
not just the it's you know identity
security is is a really fascinating
field because it it is a it's a
foundation for enabling us to continue
being digitized and being secure and and
confident in in in the digital world but
what really excites me with what you're
doing is really the the ability to take
in a really IM mature industry which is
um you know the telecommunication
industry in this case understanding it
deeply building the right relationships
and being able to at the same time
understand where the developers are at
where are the interesting use cases in
in you know the in the digitized modern
2024 gen world bridg and bu being the
platform that Bridges those things
together and I think that you know
that's a obviously a sign of of of
amazing entrepreneurship but I think
it's also just a great a great case
study and and I'm so I'm rooting for you
I'm rooting for Glide I want to read
about this case study um in business
school when I go there one day because
um it it feels like the beginning of a
case study that's what I'm trying to say
and I'm excited to follow it too so best
of luckan and and thank you very much
for joining me today perfect thank you
very much thank you